that's good no I feel good when I say
three just count it I'll just say three
count three seconds in your head then
it's all yours sir mm-hmm all right
everybody we're gonna get this countdown
going for the official recording episode
73 thank you for you guys for being
early let's get this thing rocking take
it in three sir all right and we are
live welcome to the last word with Lorca
Eno and Eve artists we are back at the
campfire what is going on sir you've
been there I've been pretty good trying
to actually play some other games mix it
up a little bit you know try a few
things
small game dropped you know last night
slash this morning so I done that for a
couple hours yeah
so before I cannot get into mind how's
the week been
what anything anything going on that
happened I know we had a cool
anniversary this week some would even up
to this week I'm gonna kind of get in
line because it's gonna lead into what
we're talking about no doubt yeah like
earlier we got a chance to play so I'm
just doing a lot of what I call
maintenance for destiny and I'm saying
juice some things I want to pursue the
bills I want to get going you know I
told you I got you know Izanami so I'm
happy about that
and I'm trying to actually working on
some cool bills right now with that as
far from Colo doubt so basically is like
right now it's like tingled orchid in
that uh energy slide and I will be
talking about what's gonna happen to
Hank and Isabella later cuz I got that
curated flavor you know saying and then
I like I said it's not is it I'm gonna
work on my heroic menagerie this weekend
because I want that catalyst I got my
juju cash out the linchpin it was on
Twitter he had got his I got I finally
got my uh my choo-choo Cal it's done but
um yeah just about build manage it's all
about builds all about getting things
ready
obviously gears can stop you for a
second Oh what's up no no you're like
all about the builds and I was like all
about bills and it just made me think of
that old song what is that song pay my
bills pay my telephone bills pay the
phone bills my Destiny's Child you
my bills together oh yeah could be a
funny song like that whistle twisting
with the density like I say grinding
that I got shared obviously touch gears
I know you've touched that as well
and yeah I know I was gonna ask you
about a certain game that dropped this
week [ __ ] you knows things so let's get
to it man
uh so yeah if you guys haven't known or
at least been watching on twitch I have
been trying to view other games because
we have this downtime between destiny
and trying to branch out cuz in the past
crazy journey of before I even touch on
what I've been playing five years of
destiny five-year anniversary was on
September 9th PR person a bunch is
really smart to handle that one because
there was a whole interview on the five
year anniversary and when you see Luke
was like didn't even know as five years
until like this morning so cool
but yeah so I played remnant which is
kind of like a Dark Soul shooter it's
like 40 bucks
like really solid game boss fight was
cool played through it solo of course as
I do but got to experience pretty solid
gunplay like actually had good feel the
guns were different liked how they were
hitting like the weight of the bullets
and stuff like for what you would call
kind of a not a big hyped game like
really really really solid move solid
man it's got go up to it which I think
they've got patch out for balancing and
stuff now too so some of the
difficulties probably been tweaked a
little bit but all mostly overall a lot
of fun cool RPG elements leveling up fun
stuff nice so finish that got to the
final boss knock it out like last week
took a little breather then gears came
out as you guys know PC ultimate game
pass was a whopping $2 $2 be two dollars
for two months and I was like my buddy
was like it's two dollars like two
months I'm like so I will say though
let's go that Microsoft Store dude I
haven't used it that much but I was like
what yeah you know it is archaic yeah
this which is a lot of stuff - it was aw
30 - a lot of stuff going to be on Steam
they have admitted defeat
we're so trust me hey like even a halo
Master Chief I believe is gonna come
steam and Xbox game pass work with that
or do you sell to go through that other
store though now yeah if you if you own
game pass you still go ahead to deal
with that stuff like I mean that still
shoot your dollies were first oh I know
it's worth two dollars I'll you that
it's two dollars cool hmm what's up
vagabond Oh shouts everyone jumping in
this mornin thank you guys for joining
us
oh yeah it's I had to like I got the
Xbox Live beta thing I got the Microsoft
Store downloaded gears which was 60 gig
would not load would not boot up would
not turn on like over and over
uninstalled it redownload it again still
didn't do it
uninstalled it uninstalled in Microsoft
Store uninstalled the xbox pc beta thing
reinstalled everything finally got it so
yeah that's like a bit but once I got in
pretty solid I will warn everybody if
you were watching this on Twitch YouTube
Archive will be fine because obviously
I'm recording it on my end but if twitch
has any like dips if we get funky if it
drops I've just had an odd connection
now it's 8 o'clock in the morning
traffic's probably not that busy on the
internet so we might be ok so maybe just
trying to play 8 o'clock at night it's
just a bad idea but while I was playing
Gears streams were questionable ok but I
beat all of gears I beat the full story
now I have never played a Gears game Wow
so I missed 1 2 3 which was all Marcus a
saga and then I miss 4 which was the
introduction of JD and Kait know and
those guys so I went back and watch kind
of like the recaps so I got an idea what
was going on I didn't get the full idea
like the locust and marina and all that
stuff it was kind of in there so then in
5 I don't know how many people loved the
ending to this yeah so I'm not gonna
spoil anything don't worry about that
but mine was more after playing multiple
shooters recently because everyone
planned destiny for 5 years and we're so
used to the way the guns feel in that
game the gunplay and almost like the
psychological satisfaction of like
exploding heads
the weight of the guns and just like
it's more than just like pulling a
trigger and it being somewhat reliable
and accurate and feeling the animation
and stuff
it's how the enemies react to your
weapon yes and that's like a weight
behind like what is your bullet do what
does your shotgun do to something is
there a stagger effect to somebody and
for me when I was playing through
specifically gears and this could be
just the way gears is um it's just been
it was the gun play for me most weapons
like especially the which was like hey
my burst was kind of okay but it was
just like I wanted like the one that I
loved and I never had enough amateur was
like the marzu mz1
it was like a fifty shot kind of scout
ish type that was the one that I feel
like I could be accurate with everything
cuz you're like unless I'm just up in
the mix and I'm probably playing it
wrong being a little more passive but I
mean if I want to get anything at range
I feel like I'm dumping a clip just to
get to them right because it's like this
wide cone that I'm trying to hit and I'm
just like like drawing outline around
their head out active reloads good
though I so that is a mechanic like I
was like what the hell's go and then it
took me a lot I was like okay I remember
hearing about that for years for because
that was before started getting that
that definitely helps boost like the
power and the speed and stuff like that
so that helps um but I will also say in
the middle of a chaotic fight when
you're jumping around try not buy
something and you're like oh let me
active reload dead there's one boss in
that game yes I do not like end of act -
would you get there I'm not a fan of
it's not the most difficult mechanic but
like if you sneeze wrong at one point
okay it's over like it's so and I've
played the dart and I guess that was a
difference - it was sitting there even
trying to explain to my wife which could
have been falling on deaf ears because
he has no point of reference which is
fine but for me it was I played Dark
Souls I played second row I played those
games that are inherently punishing
that's fine but there are
and send that one it's like it is a
predictability it is like you learn the
fight and this thing's just sometimes
just either throwing it at you and I
will say snipers in this game
holy hell man yeah yeah that's there's
no like oh let me get like oh you're in
full health oh let me get you like low
or we or no you're down you all a quick
down Snipes so there are certain things
you know just like if your ranged or you
don't jump at the perfect moment and
you're already trying to run away cuz
you know what do you gotta have some
distance to see him anyway mm-hmm you
get tagged in the back while you're
running just like insta down or yeah
absolutely so there's just some
mechanics on the it's mostly the second
boss that annoyed me in the fight
anybody watch me eventually ended up
getting him it's just was just chaotic
and crazy these games overall overall so
I will say four gears playing through
like a adventure like shooting game and
then getting like the cinematic story
moments and like the cutaways of like
the flashbacks and memories and things
like that those are something destiny
desperately that that I want to see
those types of things are amazing we get
like very little in cutscenes and stuff
like that you know your characters
actually talking cuz you're basically
playing through I played The Rose Kade
mostly so as you go through you have a
voice and that's one thing too I listen
to I don't know if you guys any of you
listen to do too it's the fun house
podcast they had both nolan north and
troy baker on there oh the voice god
knows my means oh yeah both of them were
on there like and I mean they've done
700 rooms between oh yeah so that's a
really cool listen but they were just
talking about the difference between
sorry this is a long intro for me I
apologize already but they were talking
about like the journey you go through in
a video game and kind of the importance
of voice actors it's like as you watch
an actor on screen they can have an
amazing job like Heath Ledger and the
Joker's like one that always jumps to
mind just an amazing roll and you watch
it but when you have a voice actor
playing through as uncharted or as Kate
or whatever that voice is in your head
and you are calling since clearly them
you like oh yeah you take that on and
when you go through and you have that
feeling of like I am this person and
this is how I sound
everybody was talks about Shepard
and mass effect for example I played it
but that's a big big big one um they got
David Hayter metal gear yeah during his
day that was iconic kind of kept voice
so I mean those are all yeah so listen
to that one if you can because those
that wasn't really cool listen because
those two sitting together is hilarious
but just that like when you got to see
those like cinematic experiences when
she's in a moment trapped under rock and
just like the pain the feeling the
strife like the actress did an amazing
job for her and you can like the beam
and like there's one point like I'm an
xbox game this is big come hold on I'm
enjoying wake up to copy I know it's
like I enjoyed like the voice actors is
really good like the like the cinematic
piece is the way they told the story
those little pieces those are things I
want and destiny the story in and of
itself and like it was are a new player
I am a new player completely jump I to
five with never playing no I know so
like the way it's not there for me so
and I also feel like this is the middle
of the set up of more for a six like
this truly feels like this feels like a
middle this feels right very much like a
middle like an episode two for the
prequels this feels like like they're
setting things up chess pieces are
moving there was one thing we saw like
those kind of but there's there's big
there's gonna be a six there has to be
obviously so this is so jumping into
this one felt a little weird but mine
wasn't even as much on like the story
pieces I really wish stuff like that was
in destiny but the gunplay on destiny
after even and even like on remnant and
stuff like it doesn't even touch I gave
up or that a long time ago but I could
have talked about that I guess I
realized between um I guess I'll put up
a new article check me out Lourdes
gaming down there please check it out
almost what Sheamus blog do it baby
right now working hard with me yeah man
I said that I was I was reflecting on my
thoughts about it's five years I don't
know we want to segue right now into a
blow if you save that nope and it's like
um yeah like I'm just like y'all
I've never played a game like this
before I've never played like I've had
games that have a good run six months a
year you know and you play here and
there you still play it on occasion but
I'm talking about playing a game this is
where des T's will plan a game with the
same level of intensity that you played
it when you first got it the first month
that's destiny like that is unheard of
so I was like mom I'll say okay so what
is it and like I said Otto who is again
you got to justice the art style the
skyboxes you don't understand and then
it's the gunplay it's the gun flavor oh
is it
there's nothing everything you said
whether it comes to the field the gum
aim the impact on the enemies you're
saying like it's nothing
beating bungee when it comes to pure gum
and the fact that each gun is distinct
you know I'm saying has a even down to
the sounds like I'm pulling out is an
ominous sounds like I got a samurai
sword when I get you know I'm saying
when you yank it out like just the
little nuances it's just it's pretty
amazing so long yeah man let's just uh
and obviously we you know this podcast
as a result you know I mean because of
destiny meeting people friendships you
know I mean he's been iron law podcast I
mean look iron model what is that come
on it's founded in destiny he does
everything I've done is founded in this
damn game so just like it's just been
way about I just look back on like wow
like I saw your tweet and I was like
yeah you know saying I felt it you know
say I really thought it came from the
heart and is literally how I felt it
which is like this is an amazing
community amazing game I've never
experienced a game like this and I can't
wait to see where this thing all go bad
but five years I saw that coming around
and I waited a long time throughout the
data like a lot of people were writing
stuff which were really cool like the
journey I had been through and stuff
like that it was like I waited a long
time through that I was like I gotta
write something this has been too much
it's like too much of me I played the
Alpha before things were out there
playing beta I was like played started
had my friends who started with me and
then the journeys for them dropped off
I've been with it started my channel
like I mean
I do this stuff now again I do this
stuff because of that damn game like
like it's it's destiny like I went to
Guardian Cana I met you went to destiny
Con this year met so many more people
which was crazy peopled like not like
there were two people that recognized me
but one of them regular like a family
like literally like a few hours from
getting there
mm-hmm it was like just it was a family
that came up met me they were the nicest
people whole family knew that watched my
videos together and stuff and there was
a father and son at play and the mom was
there with them and it was just like
they were really cool family and they
just came up and like had this game
never been invented I would have never
been in Florida seeing the resort like
the amount donated to charity I think I
don't know if it's close to like cuz
they did 4 million this year like it was
close to three last year I don't know if
they're close to like 10 million but
they have to be close just throw this
community it's community
it's it's insane and the last point it's
my story is kind of funny because you
know as much as I love Bungie I remember
when they announced and I was in alpha
and all that stuff and I did love the
Alpha Mu Alpha looks good this thing my
potential
I'm height so my height level was very
high then the game came out I'll never
forget I kind of soured I got tomorrow
you know level beat the story I didn't
get to the max level cat what it was a
25 26 whatever they keep the dirty and
I'm just like like I was be honest I was
like yeah right so I left it alone and I
never forget shout out the sinister shot
a lot of people in clean they let yo we
were to get you to 30 you know I think I
needed boots or whatever they dropped
for me to finally get it I got it and it
was faulty glass like what's this what's
this thing I talk about no she tries to
raid whatever all right so I'm like I'm
literally about to trade the game like I
was I was done I was like I did
everything I need to do I've seen it all
this giant is a and I really didn't like
the end I remember was like be the end
it was stranger yeah yeah whatever
you know yeah you know what was the joy
the classic line like oh no i'm like
this i was a hater of this game make it
be clear so then i'm
we get to joint we do vault the glass
and I'm like whoa this is different and
that's why I was listening to Luke talk
about vault which he also agreed is to
go but we gonna get it then I'm act like
he said give it up to the chair yeah but
um yeah man like I just listened to him
and they were like then he asked him
like you know Bregman I was like did you
know what you had at that point he was
like no and then something happened in
his family at yeah the other way so he
to get the chance to see a lot of
reactions of people playing or to blast
like on the raids and that's what it was
but it was just for first-person console
we've never seen anything like that and
it was just a togetherness the community
just it was just everything about the
structure of it platforming you know it
everything you know and um yeah that
changed but I was okay this is something
they've got something here they just got
a build on it they got to clean up a
couple of things they got to get the
narrative a little better but I said the
foundation gum play art stock skyboxes
and I found out about Lord and I was it
oh yes Lord music oh I could of me about
something I completely forgot to put a
damn article yeah that's the thing I
also champion for which is yo Destiny's
got some of the best music in gaming I'm
getting upset I'm gonna have to go to
Geoff Keighley and say look if destino
it I don't care if they don't win hottie
not getting nominated I got that come on
so many though
um that's one thing I'm gonna fight
about desti don't just even destiny
without boy who's not there no more what
what's funnier now Mario the commonness
in the spheres oh boy you could play
that no mistress somewhere we could we
could make money they do know I mean
it's been an amazing five-year journey
like the place it went through and that
was the thing I mean he said in the
interview was like he saw people on
Twitter or Rhetta basically just saying
it's like it's a shooter and it's a raid
a shoot it's like those two pushed
together and that's why it's like I mean
well the interesting thing they talked
about though - that's not the raid they
had planned do you know what the
combined raid with some folks that was
actually planned for like their story
and that's also again goes back to just
prove the disjointed release of Destiny
one and the story that was and didn't
happen and could have been all those
things they had crota and Oryx and all
that stuff is like one connected thing
so it's like how all that got
disconnected or forced I don't know if
there were people involved or stories
got for whatever happened like Oryx and
that like that shows you from the
beginning they wanted this crota Oryx
story to be one unit yeah and it ended
up getting like totally separated told
his but then think about all the turn
them all they had I mean I don't know if
you've read all blessed fighting pixels
by Jason Schreyer like this game was
literally piece mailed together at the
last bit like they had so many obstacles
just to get the game out the door but
it's truly amazing that it even launched
and then people stood by it in the state
it was in right because we still saw the
potential we still had the core elements
that all the things you're talking about
you know and um yeah man it's just it's
truly it's truly amazing that what it's
become and now I'm like you're five
years
Wow yeah it's been an insane journey I
feel like I'm here to talk about it for
the entire podcast but I'm sure we have
to move on
but yeah it's been amazing and it's like
you think look back and think of all
we've been through it's been there's
some crazy moments like one of my best
back there so no it's been it's been a
ton of fun so for the kind of funny
interview I think we touched on some of
the stuff he went back talking about
kind of the nostalgia his journey up
into it how it kind of got started in
hey do you want to work on raids he got
into that hey do you want to run the
game and he's just got imposter sent him
the whole time but he's he's really cool
about it so it's good listening so it's
kind of funny Luke Smith you guys didn't
catch it it was like three days ago so
definitely check that one out it was
really cool it's out there for and it's
just if you're a fan in this game go
check it out cuz it'll send you back on
nostalgia but also you remind you and
show you things that they've gone
through to the journeys they've been
through what the developments like and I
think one thing they brought up that I
think a lot of people say they may
empathize with but then sometimes
they're like I just want my game like
they don't really is he was just saying
some things that are really easy that
you would think are really easy to do
are not in no way yeah cuz that's the
whole point of some people like well
what's this development cycle like what
should just be like flip a switch and
everybody's like that's not his example
was like there's not like a push of push
a fun button and everything's just it's
not there that was really good but then
on the other side he wouldn't give an
example because it's like one of my devs
what a shame some well yeah yeah well
the other side who's like something you
think that might be really hard could
actually be really easy and he's like
I'm not gonna give an example cuz the
devil might be like dude I may make that
easy but it's not easy so his dancing
game you know he's on point he's got
some biddies d.school yeah it's deep
school yeah he worked it but no that was
actually cool cuz I mean that's one of
those you think about be like oh what's
this you know let's add a gun that was
one of the examples how hard is it to
make a go you forget about those things
man and to make it distinct from all the
other exactly what you just said earlier
what makes this game like every gun
feels different shoots different
different animation okay like so when
you go to make a gun like I mean in your
mind what goes into making a gun in
yours I mean forget about I'm just sorry
let's forget about the the
you'll gunplay impact feel range pull a
drop off right we gotta admit these
moles this our team just a design like
it's just I look at born and tough to me
it looks like this sick dark Corvette
looks like the Batmobile like it just
these just sexy designs and then we take
for granted ornaments and you know
Gjallarhorn the epic the Imperial mr.
wolf you know yeah I'm just talking
about one a pure aesthetic level whew is
touching him right now now you combine
that would feel with weight with the
barrel on a gun remember what the point
he said about the hand cannon that
iconic thing when you see your character
like this right few games don't have
that and I'm saying just that whole that
whole mythos about a hand can't like
they've got a lot of things that they
just do well from a system fundamental
standpoint they just do tremendous and
let's just call it what it is I'm I said
no game is seeing destiny on gunplay I'm
sorry I don't I don't care I'm call me
biased
I've been around on my show surely show
me out baby she'll tell you right now
play them all not you even the biggest
destiny haters will tell me like does
anything going you can't say that
gunplay is airtight no no it's
absolutely solid and that's one of those
things that's why when it comes to them
making a weapon it can't just be like
slap another weapon in there they want
it to feel have a right feel have the
animation be just the right about have
the the reload the look of a gun the
class of weapon that it's in the way it
fires like all of those pieces go into
it on top of it working in how does it
feel in PvE
how does it work in game and what's the
damage numbers in there what does the
PvP feel is it gonna break the meta are
we gonna have like a reclusive PvE
example there's so much that they have
to equate for for just one weapons now
would I like more of them yep
straight-up would absolutely would
because the importance of those weapons
is one of the things that makes destiny
what it is right so having more options
for those or having it refresh at the
vendors that we keep asking for that's
not a small undertaking as they're
saying but it is one a lot of the
playerbase of values so I think for them
cranking up their evaluation adding it
higher on the priority list and is one
of those things I think many would like
to see yeah absolutely
switches hating on us right now oh my
god yeah yeah you can just refresh y'all
just just rock with us on that refresh
I saw we gonna be here we ain't going
yeah that's which will be a little weird
today I am sorry actually not yeah guys
right now so yeah thank you Prescott
mm-hm
so yeah it's I mean it is his journey
that he talks about his journey just to
get there me that you think it's five
years so nine years for him yeah we're
his journeys tremendous I didn't even
know he came from the whole sure almost
like a journalistic background yep yeah
like that to be a design and they'd like
to hear his story of life okay so Westar
it is like how do I just do this things
like well you have to have a bill you
like bill like it like that whole you
know this build with this number oh yeah
yeah dope dope so own I salute the look
man I mean I got so much respect from
him you know obviously the history of
the game and just to see his role of
what he said is guiding use a great
analogy which is like I think a fleet
nanny just getting everyone makes sure
we're in the right direction but it
knows at the same time if another of
some other ships say hey we found this
hey it's cool to steer it you know
Alton yes right that's cool now I would
love to be one of my goals is at some
point I've got to get out to Seattle
I've got a if there's any way I could do
a studio tour I don't know if they do
that but I would love to see that
because it's at a point not he it's
undeniable I've liked I liked a lot of
developers over the years Namco you know
you name it but bungees clearly by far
it's by default my
favorite now go out to the buff [ __ ] oh
yeah can I get called back take the trip
to the mecca exactly and then so yeah it
was cool just to see but was like when
you think about the studio working on it
they've almost been on this thing for a
decade yeah and he said for him I think
it was that next series is gonna be 40
and it's actually gonna be a decade that
he's been working on it he's like it's a
quarter my life bro
proud of them boys man like I said we
give him crap you know we're passionate
but let's be real we do it because we
still love this damn game we're still
addicted to this game as much as we talk
crap anybody are that's the funny
feelings so lame yeah that's dope nice
Aloha salute the buns you salute the
five years it's our anniversary last
words look I know it's a little for sure
man but his game so yeah one more thing
he touched on there which is gonna kind
of roll into what we've got coming next
there was a big question as we know are
more 2.0 is coming big changed the way
armor works we've got stats we've got
static mods that we can use like you
unlock them you don't consume them and
the big question that was asked was are
we gonna get a weapons 2.0 now before we
get into all the sandbox changes we will
say one thing so what does the big thing
of the [ __ ] that basically you almost
said it was weapons 2.0 what what what
do you got yeah man it made that
announcement man and reference to home
actually was your tweet I saw it first
yeah which was in conjunction with how
the mods I believe would play so is that
at the start of its sandbox weapons
updates just the weapons changes general
under the combatants part under come yes
yes yes okay so we got minor okay there
we go bow so armed weapon mods are now
treated as reusable unlocks instead of
consumables any module having the
inventory will be converted to unlocks
this gives players the opportunity to
play with different mods more frequently
if the only copy of a mod you have is
already in a gun you will need to
reacquire one to unlock it so that is
tremendous I have a question though okay
cuz um I'm a little scared looks good I
love
I love this whole I should have just
selfishly about one guy oh yeah like I
got my breakneck bro and it was hard to
get that rampage speck so my question is
do I got the farm rampage back am I
gonna lose it out of my yep you gotta
get rampage back again for just sir get
on that natto show no love with that mod
bro she'll give me like a bunch of
dragonfly speck and all this other stuff
but that mod takes forever for me to get
damn I got a farm that I can't be having
my big [ __ ] with on the Buffs going on
but continue but yeah so yeah weapons
2.0 is not happening as the biggest one
but that was before we knew in the 12
the weapons were gonna have consistent
mods like that you can basically use the
ones that you have and I think van
copacobana said it right I think weapons
2.0 would be I don't think that would
fit mm-hmm I don't think I mean that is
part of the game is literally RNG on the
weapons
it's like whether it's Borderlands or
whether it's other things like the the
RNG on the weapons is the one of the
biggest pieces of this game what are the
roles that you get on what are those if
you are if you're able I mean the fact
that we could pick a masterwork in the
menagerie was already like some people
were like oh we're flirting with it
getting too easy to get your stuff can
you get too many drops and all that
stuff mm-hmm
so I don't think there needs to be a
weapons 2.0 I just think there needs to
be like shadow keep perks we need more
perks to pick from on the guns that are
or you need to wait some of them better
so they're worth more than outlaw
rampage skip kill clip multi kill clip
like we need more options besides those
and I think that's the big wait because
if we go into shadow keep when we're
still always going for my chat do I want
my rampage feeding frenzy weapon mmm
isn't that still all I'm going for and I
think that's probably the bigger the
bigger one weapons two point no it's not
like hey I just get a blank gun
let me pick all the perks on it that's
you're gonna run they don't have enough
guns for that they can't build their
weapons that way I agree yeah I like it
I mean in a sense it's like a you know
half way to play know in a sense anyway
because once you've unlocked it then you
have it so I'm fine with this this is I
agree I don't want to mess with the
integrity of what the loop system is in
terms of gunplay so I'm cool with this
with this choice yeah and we'll have the
rolls still on the armor cuz you're
gonna be gonna be gone for perfect stat
rolls maybe another build on your stats
and stuff like that there's gonna be
some options there not a ton but I mean
you're gonna look at every piece that of
ARMA that drops just in case especially
to get to the higher stuff but when it
comes to weapons I think our biggest
thing is just more variety different
perks that have different functions they
start they've introduced like
swashbuckler and multi kill clip and
once you punch and they've added more to
the pool but they haven't like opened
the MA all the perks to all the guns
okay so it'd be nice to be like hey can
any gun have any or I mean yeah sniper
rifles don't need like hipfire grip
right but that should not yeah it's like
yeah like there's certain perks that yet
it should from archetype should be
removed but on the other side there are
some perks that have been introduced in
like annual pass stuff and expansions
that I would like to just be able to see
role on a better Devils or a nameless
midnight and stuff like that to actually
have an option of you know any gun I
look out potentially it's like oh this
is old it can't get the new perks I
don't want that feeling anymore
I want I'd be able to say any these guns
can give these perks I mean if I can get
a feeding frenzy rampage on a nameless
midnight with buff that's coming mmm I
mean that might actually a viable guttin
so hey but until that happens that I
still am limited of what I'm looking for
so that's my thoughts on 2.0 and mostly
not even 2.0 just my thoughts on weapons
so what about you any anything else from
that interview I'm it was a cool one I
listened it was like an audience but it
was right his background you know the
journey you know obviously hearing about
you know the rate creation um
so many standouts man um
seanny thing I think we touched the
majority the ones that I wanted to hit
put on just to see him you know still
going strong got the vision going you
know he got D threes coming he's got
some idea what he wants to do there and
on I just like how you know pretty much
he's meeting with all the teams and I'm
saying it he's basically getting that
structure of where they want to do
things and I love it I love it my cell
just keep it going
I'd like to see more like this I liked
his you know breakdown of how he came
down with the directors you know writing
the whole direct oh yeah I want to see
that honesty via the cutting floor room
for the edits out cuz they talked about
langmaster workers I'm like dude you
have any idea how many people want to
read about your thoughts after what
course like the entire community wants
to know absolutely absolutely dropping
gems just a fantastic those one of those
interviews I was like I just look good
but I like this is this is love for the
age did it perfect time and anniversary
right you know as you know we host you
know you appreciate stuff it's a great
episode yeah that was a great one and
that leads into as we talk about weapons
and the changes that are coming twelve
this week drops and just finished us in
the face with a bit more so we'll go
through the sandbox first the future for
the last which may be out of order but
that's what we're gonna do because we
were to talk about weapons you so as
mentioned previously shadow keep is
giving a sandbox update to some things
like heavy ammo and supers and orbs and
classes and now we get weapons just go
we got weapons so they said they did a
deep dive into the abilities in shadow
keep this week they want to give patch
know previews for weapons a lot of it is
gonna be different in PvE and
environments specifically a lot of this
is PvE focused actually with relation to
weapons and dealings with enemies and
different types of enemies as well the
first thing they actually touch on is
one thing but I guess added it got added
in a little later because I saw like a
correction from dmg so combatants in
general and this is something I guess I
don't even know if I knew I mean I
always know you can kind of smashed
little guys in the face like thrall you
just figure like you're weak I'm gonna
like if you quit you're like this just
big anyway I kind of figured that was it
minor enemies quote rank and file no
longer take more precision damage than
other enemies mmm these enemies
previously took twice as much damage to
their precision hit locations than
enemies of higher ranks you will still
deal with precision damage but this is
now entirely dependent on the weapon as
it as it is for higher ranked enemies
mmm so that's one I didn't even think
about so I guess like if you still shoot
a throttle you're probably still gonna
kill a Thrall but I guess now like just
a red barn knight might be a little
harder to kill right yeah like that like
the bigger they're bigger beefier red
bars not the or not the majors not the
bosses but the red bars could be a
little more of a gonna keep you busy
like yeah the ads are gonna be like if
you get rushed it's gonna be a bigger
issue it yeah that's the fob I got ya
that's literally the fob I got like that
there's no more just completely hot but
a knife in mowing through exactly yeah
so you go weapon changes in general as
we said weapon mods will be reusable I
mean that's just cool so that's cool
that's I think you only need to keep one
of each mod done by the time this comes
around so you can delete every other mod
but one yeah I think so just buy one as
long as you have one one version of it
not in a weapon yep you'll be fine
yeah I just gotta make sure and look if
I've got like my rampages and my
dragonflies of course my hoarder self
probably has like twelve of everything
but I will say rampage was hard to come
by like if I look at rampage it's
probably gonna be ya know I know the
stream is going yep so but yeah like the
weapons that we've got coming are gonna
be like using the mods that we've got
which is cool I just have to hope that
when it comes to my mods that I've got a
rampage sitting down I'm like looking
through them like do I have it do I have
it do I have it cool I've got it okay oh
yeah literally I gotta do this thing I
gotta do this yeah I have I've
I have light okay so I don't spend mods
that often shocking I'm a hoarder but
when it comes to like rampage I have
like eight of everything I've even got
like four Dragonfly but I have I have to
ramp it I have to rampage but like I
have like ten of everything else just in
normal mass like rampage is hard to come
by so like that's one of those for sure
that if you don't have it you're gonna
want to jump on that one but if I can
just hold on to one and just put rampage
everywhere yes beautiful that's why I
gotta get it back yeah baby right deal
what but that's also like if you want to
test that hey a does counterbalance feel
on this one if you don't want a dog log
into light IgG see what the recoil
Direction is like oh let me switch it
out okay regal Direction is actually
worse with this one let me go put in
quick fire Schlage or something like
that who know it's like I just think
about the ramification of you know when
you do make the mistake and now you
don't have to shard like the sharding
was so annoying because there's some
guns and I'm like yo this is a good role
it has a mod that maybe I don't want in
it but the gun I don't want to get rid
of but now but you know I'm saying it it
just puts you in this bad position so
tremendous tremendous design choice to
have that free it's basically weapons it
is basically rubber - boy don't like 1.7
Zack there you go wait but I mean yeah
the mods the reusable just of the mod so
you can toy around with them your perks
are still gonna be what rolls but using
mods more freely I think is a good thing
as you mentioned before or somebody I've
heard of multiple places like armor 2.0
is gonna be these mods that are reusable
you unlock him you're good it was gonna
be really weird for new players a new
light coming in being like what the
hell's up these weapon mods they go away
but the armor ones don't why is what is
the system different so it's all the
same Universal across the board they
just hadn't got there yet they hadn't
pulled back the curtain so mm-hmm that's
gonna be a big one like I don't want to
settle
that's huge I just hope we get more mod
and I think that just goes along with
this system of the artifact and stuff
because there's some artifact mods that
are our artifact things that our weapon
mods and if some of those were
consumable and some weren't I was just
gonna get bizarre so I probably could
put two and two together before but I
never actually made that leap yes I feel
like but yeah we were coming so I'm
gonna let you take the damage buffs and
then we'll talk about each one as we go
through but I want you to talk about the
damage rebuff so on your liking oh I'm
doing this because I want like your your
numbers react when you're like auto
rifles get blank I want you to be like
oh I want to are you yeah I want you so
let's get it let's get it man like the
oh yeah weapon changes man so auto
rifles right on cue
PvE damage increased between 30 and 25
percent depending on combatant rank
that's serious that's very cool that's
big Bogues PvE damage increased by 31%
against minor enemies and 26% against
major enemies fixed an issue where bow
draw times are displayed incorrectly in
the inspection screen you're a goal guy
sees moments okay well I ran you through
shattered throne with my bow I remember
but there's a reason for that bows in
and of themselves are actually pretty
powerful because you have 60 shots that
hit harder than most things they hit
scan when they're a full draw and then
on top of that they do hit like a small
truck yes you smashed 20 to 25 to 30% on
top of there mm-hmm I mean I don't know
yeah I'll be curious I'll begin we got
hand cannons a lot going on with headers
there's a lot of stuff to break down on
highways PvE damage against minor
enemies increased by 30%
this one's critical now to lightweight
and adaptive hand cannons use a new
firing animation while aiming down
sights this change was made to increase
weapon accuracy when firing these
weapons as fast as possible for example
currently players can shoot faster than
the weak whole animation of the 140 and
150 archetypes so while the hand cannon
looks to have fully reset from recoil
the following projectile will be shot as
if the weapon was still in the recoil
state as huge reduce the effect reduced
the effect of the range that has on
damage range fallout effective range for
this weapon okay
let's stop right here because that's
terrifying this get to it reduce the
effect of rain the range that has LAN
damage range fall off now the way in my
mind I read that mmm arrange that is
important because that determines right
where your weapon will have its like
fall off a cliff oh and especially for a
hand cannon so if they reduce the effect
of that stat has on range drop off I'm
gonna get like half mapped by a damn
handgun and it feels like do you think I
think they way the wording is a little
confusing I mean do you think it's gonna
extend the range of shorten at first I'm
gonna show the range its worded like
that was poorly worded them it's
committed let's reduce the effect the
range that has on damage range fall-off
not in a sounds like what you just said
right it sounds like reducing the effect
of damage range for your range that
determines how much of effect it has on
range fall right so he's just worded
incorrectly because if we looked at the
prior pack or let's go is well you think
it's more like the higher the range the
less of a boost it gives you like if
you're so like or do you think it even
if you keep bump on the range so you get
a Duke that's like 92 range
you're not gonna map you're not gonna
lightly be able to map somebody anymore
because the range isn't pushing the
damage fall-off as far do you think that
might be what they mean the vibe I get
again that bollocks seems poorly worded
very Bob it was the example I need that
if we scroll up underneath the shadow
keep sandbox update weapon right second
paragraph it says in terms of how these
changes will have impact your PvP
experience a few weapons and archetypes
are being buffed
while some be more aggressive range
fall-off to give breathing room to scout
rifles and other weapons so the vibe I
get when I read this is that they're
they're reducing hand cannons we're
gonna get two pulses we and gets the
other ones right that range full of
thing I mean they're increasing that
range photo so that they're gonna get
more hit for other way so that Scouts
can
live at the distance they need to live
because that's really the problem the
problem is scout should be the effective
long-range weapon besides us time
obviously and I'm saying that can be
consistent but it had I'm sorry bye go
it's time to reap yes it was a good run
no get to play with something else to
get a new toy you can put them that
dusty Vigo that's clean oiled and used
constantly is town what vault is dusty
what are you talking about okay so here
what do you look down okay we'll get
some bowls rifles of the second listing
machine guns and we gotta talk about
this whole difference between the way
this is worded machine guns I'll just
search it real quick PvE damage against
minor enemies increased by 25% all these
minor increases by the way basically
help balance out the difference in the
precision damage in case you guys were
wondering they're trying to keep that
somewhat even they're just changing the
way some of it works yeah so this this
is where this one and pulse rifles both
read differently than hand cannons and
this is why I kind of wonder
machine guns increase the effects of
damage follow up on this are kits weapon
archetype mm-hmm and then they do the
same thing for increase the effects of
written damage range fall off on this
archetype so damage range is gonna hit
machine guns and pulse rifles harder but
the way they weren't hand cannons reduce
the effect the range that has on damage
range fall ofin I guess that's right
mate maybe in PvE
remember it's my hand can every it
doesn't specify well yeah well no but
it's still worded differently I'm
thinking like it is worried differently
you're like reducing the effect the
range that has on damage range fall-off
effective range I guess maybe the
effective range you my guess is they're
trying to not let you push a hand cannon
out as far if you max it out you give it
ricochet rounds it has like the perfect
roll or it's almost like a Duke with 95
is stupidly far yes because I mean it's
a 110 so I think if they reduce what
like if that range is 95 it doesn't push
the fall-off as far I think is that so I
think it still goes in line with
bringing things down it's just that's me
and Holly worried yeah
arguing cuz again we because last week
we all we all agree in the current meta
hand cannons can compete way too far
with whatever machine wins on PC is
broken it's yeah
machine guns way too far you play gambit
people are mapping you with machine gun
so again these are things that they
recognize a problem in the same thing
with pulse I mean pulses I'm juju right
bro I am mapping people with Chu Chu
it's for better mean like jutsu for me
does juju feels about what a pulse rifle
should be compared to my go figure I
should say okay Michael figure blast
furnace those two feel like those feel
like near Scouts yeah and I think those
are the ones that are not letting Scouts
shine which is understandable but if I
get a pulse rifle with like 95 range
yeah but should be hitting pretty far
though right absolutely
with all right so my baby pulses let's
go go for it archetype specific damage
changes impacts both PvE and PvP rapid
pulse fires now deal 14 and 20 frames up
from 13 and 21 point four so one point
boost on body and almost over two point
boost on precision
like once a picture like pose baby dust
off that close actually one I don't know
if you have horrors least I don't when
you get that one from was that one
that's from the corrupted strike
corrupted knife uh-huh okay okay yeah
that one's for grant I think that's
cursed record title dude that thing I've
used it in PvP and it didn't quite like
have the speed but it was pretty good
like it's damn quick and it's just a
crew dude it's so fast and I can see
that being a thing and now high impact
on the other side going from Tony going
from 20 to 21 so up 1 and up 1 in a high
impact pulse what's your high impact
pulse what are you talking about bro you
just you don't even think about right
you just earned the pinnacle of it just
recently I didn't pinnacle you
oh just readdress yeah that's the one
they're talking about great church is
gonna be lit think about it cuz you're
gonna get that buff with what high
impact yeah and then would you get
desperado oh yeah man yeah I got Rick's
want to be a problem because that was
one thing I was thinking about I was
like coming into the next season I might
okay they got up are certain things
there's certain things they looking at
that are not usually not like I still
feel so bad for Reggie so I was like
it's really not in a good place
I hope they do something for but I
thought they were gonna buff the gun on
an individual level but little host
archetype those two architect reflux is
going to be dirty as it should be
based on the people who put in that work
I'm again oh my god so what did you have
to do to get it the first time when it
was read Rick's Claymore oh man I think
it was old school old school fabled or
whatever I mean I failed but you know
what was that I just like literally
maxing it it was we had asked a chair I
can't remember it was old school rules
like they were still figuring that stuff
out yeah so I'm gonna assume it was on
one of those high rankings bro to get
rhetorics it was it was an issue
it had to be up there I know it wasn't
as I know it was hard cuz not next and
nobody got it I know two people gonna
had it the original way but I will
definitely say the journey to render its
broadsword is a long journey and alive
PvE resets and one I'm almost there I'm
almost there dude I'm a flag are you
gonna try and get it this season are you
working on all I'm getting done I'm
getting are you that are you on that
step I'm literally on the last step I
got I got the four resets and I'm like
on the last circle before I get five so
I just got a play like a couple like
maybe four or five just wait for like
Ironman or one of those but they're
buffs coming for all the Valor and stuff
so that'll be coming so yeah yeah the
red Drake's
it's a long journey though man it is a
long journey it means that quest like
okay follow the people I'm not saying
the other one was easier but this ones
are crying dude
as a crying and I hate is a grunt the 20
bounties that oh my god what else 75
matches of each do evasive yeah it is
long in the precision parts and that
it's a long run long rifle sure all
right so I shot the Slayer you say
Claymore required fabled in calm so that
was it fabled is only 2100 I guess it's
just people are getting more used to
going to that now there's gonna be it
wasn't it wasn't it classic you know
gladiator meta where you went up
remember they had back then they had
losing streaks remember sorry I'll row
getting those for them they had the
losing streaks for a decent amount of
time yes was not rough meta baby
mmm what the boys got they just got an
ornament right well he goes like it or
it looks slightly different I mean you
know it's like if you ever see Claymore
that's that's the og like no one can get
that name anymore so is yeah this is me
this is now rifles PvE damage increased
by thirty six to eighteen percent
depending on the combatant rink now
scour he's got hit by like 30 they got
like a 15% buff which still wasn't
enough we're going over that this or
getting 15 plus more either plus three
or even more up above that almost 20%
above what they used to be sure oxygen
sr3 oxygen sr3 Polaris Lance Alerus lays
we don't sky burners gonna play sky
I almost played with that the other a -
I was going through doing just goofy
loadouts in night falls and I think
solar burning him like I ended up using
like Prometheus cuz I was just goofing
around 3/4 rifles that day but I almost
pulled out sky burn it's just be like
dude you can just like
strafe and let Auto a him do its thing
just be like Bob and we bothered we even
let me on Owen yeah that's my own that
mmm
might leave some I got
got a sick what was it uh something
Talan what's that Chewie from I'm banner
it's a scout for my banners yeah I know
what you're talking about
yeah I forget that one and also baby
Polaris when I cause MK 11 ISM the
letter O the legendary version of it
yeah it's the brain tag rwp yeah
Brady yet I will yo guys what yeah I
came out wait I got my oxygen on deck I
have it with a dragon fly speck with
that or an automatic perk it's gonna be
crazy
fine I got a talons of the eagle with
outlaw have a great love rampage mmm
salute The MITRE you know might is
coming back strong baby PvP might it's
gonna be back or yeah yeah PvP that's
computer Jade wait a minute Oh Jade yeah
but here's the thing
although Jade's ever gonna be great the
perk on Jade still annoys the hell out
of me it's not noise me you know what I
miss with this side note remember Balu
in Gemini
really general body shots
anyway here's the thing no whiff again
it's sink Scouts PvE but we all know
where's the PvP Buffett yeah why is that
not mention I don't know stop with that
I'm a little nervous that one would
assume like you've got weak hapless no
one's using Scouts in PvP no one like
we've got to get Scouts going if they
don't some of these range fall offs
unless they're more drastic than we
think they are
mmm I don't think those range faults are
gonna be enough to make Scouts that good
without buffing their damage a little
bit like I mean take it back even just
give them like take electives I don't
know that's weird maybe not always of
notes I'm not sure that's true that's
true that's true
maybe like I said hey just giving us a
taste cuz it would make absolutely no
sense so you know anyway shout out to
people using sidearms PV increased of
minor you baby get your rec again
literally minor and majors get a 16%
buff
party oh I don't know what's real quick
sigh boy we really do what what are we
doing with where you add these do you
think I don't know yeah I'm not gonna
you okay so that's the weird and that's
where they're in a weird spot like and
you keep like I they almost need like a
it's like your backup pistol just needs
to be one of those that you have
infinite ammo of like that's your like
default gun should be sought you run out
of everything you still get your little
peashooter sidearm play fun
yeah peepees at Walther PPK but I mean
that's the because I think I'm like okay
so if I take and I put a sidearm into
even my energy slot right so what if my
top slot is gonna be whether it's a
primary whether it's a special shotgun
or Scout like I'm hitting something a
little farther range or hand cannons
gonna be a little close-up that doesn't
that doesn't help any range that I'm not
gonna be able to hit with the other one
mm-hm and I'm definitely not gonna use a
sidearm as my primary and then say like
my sniper rifles my second area or
something like that I'm not that's not a
that's not a viable load up that's not a
thing but they just need a little slot
on the dudes holster and be like what is
your your backup pistol I just don't see
like I I think when they initially in d1
right now this is prior I think the
problem is submachine guns have taken
that role what's the same spot but it's
the same spots open the sub is gonna do
most like especially whatever close with
all the stuff that's around out here so
it's like subs are really doing that
better then it's like shotgun is really
the equalizer right so I just don't see
a place of what range it really works
and I'm worried about the archetype as a
whole I gave Mamie that goal I just
cannot see you but even if you buff it
right let's say you go crazy with the
buffs hey are you still gonna take that
over a shotgun are you still gonna take
that over I don't know
it needs a boost that's for sure I don't
know what is wait land with that they
are in a tough spot with side off
anywhere let you get a samurai
sniper rifles PvE damage increased by
47% against minors may miners are minors
but still boost but we're all we're
dropping the precision so that's gonna
kind of equate cuz Nevers hit hard on
precision anyway 20% for others though
is pretty sizable so something like
Darcy hitting 20% harder is a chunk like
that's exotic sniper rifle perk damage
bonuses baby well hold on exotic sniper
rifle perk damage bonuses had been
modified to compensate for this change
and they will not receive the full
benefits as a result so ya Izanagi or
tsunami I never forget because once the
large ones the name yeah you got whisper
you got em Darcy all those aren't
probably gonna get too much from this
sadly so question for you mister whisper
mister whisper are you will you ever
dust it off and bring it back back down
okay even with the the luna faction
nerves the will they ever come back in
play for you I don't know honestly as
the reloads will be as reloading will
not be as like easy right
having the continuous 18 shot damage
having somebody that could go dump it
heavy ammo break out of it enemy like
guaranteed with your mod with like the
finisher maybe depending on if damage
cycles if you can't one phase a boss
like there may be enough cycle time that
it's actually still able to put out if
you put out 18 bullets a whisper mmm-hmm
I think that's what you can get up to
they nerf they did they no they took it
down to nine they took it back up to 18
but they took off the road that's right
but even if you get 18 19 20 bullets out
of whisper it still hits hard hard with
breathing without stopping and if you in
a full stack of that still even in a
damage cycle that's a chunk and if
you're forced to do damage cycles
because they don't want us to one phase
and you can get like heavy ammo brake
pickups it's possible that might still
be good like it it has it has more
potential I feel like now that it hasn't
a long time and at 20% that's not gonna
go on to exotics read the bullet below
it oh what what I thought I said I
exotic
sniper rifle perk damage bonuses so that
would be like boxer breathing or
reliving but I'm saying the actual gun
itself in its normal state should get to
20 okay yeah they won't receive the full
result of the damage buff so yeah it's
not full but it might get a little more
so but I mean still like I think going
into this new world of not free reloads
they're gonna be faster which honestly
works for that's and having probably
cycles of bosses and stuff like that I
think this is probably gonna be likely a
thing that actually might have a chance
keep that video going come on keep that
video going keep it going baby yeah that
snipers I think they're gonna hit hard
man they got David they're gonna really
be and I think a legendary sniper meta
will will improve yeah that'll be the
big one cuz I mean snipers and it's I
don't know it always feels weird in a
sniper in PvE and just some of those
perks on there when you're like oh get
multiple kills with the sniper I'm like
I'm not picking off thrall with a sniper
that's not its purpose never has never
will be some perks I'm like in theory no
just even in theory no hmm submachine
guns PvE damaged increased against minor
and majors by 22.5% definitely go equip
that Rekluse on day one of shadow keep
mm-hmm aggressive frame um submachine
guns which I don't even know what that
would be there's a couple examples below
remove the intrinsically 'ls bonus
damage at close range didn't even know
that was the thing this bonus was 10%
but was unintentionally always active no
nope I don't know what aggressive frame
well let me look at your clothes here
real quick now I'm kind of curious what
is a reclusive submachine gun for
cluesive submachine gun it's scared
[Laughter]
[Music]
note that don't count
adaptive frame lightweight frame do I
have an aggressive frame I don't even
know if I do
precision frame holy hell is there one
I've got precision okay hard truths that
is technically an aggressive shame
oppressive shame aggressive a-frame
submachine gun like that's the only one
that I've got hard truths and that is
the only one that has an aggressive
frame on it might not be a lot of uh uh
that's the only one so that's really
weird not a big deal obviously but they
said this bonus damage has when we are
the same hold all a job to Jim oh he
said I closed SMG is aggressive and all
that bad I brought that's good because I
want to use that thing okay I'm gonna
some jjigae I've been really not in PvE
no MPV no I like it like see something
like well I see huckleberry down there
we'll get to in a minute like
huckleberry is always fun man or just
moan through thralls oh dude that is fun
to use got the catalyst right like that
is built for well hmm what does that
place call your bluff
yes blind well I was like well blind
well yeah that place is built for blind
well just mowing stuff down so the bonus
damage hasn't been moved to the base
damage for 750 rpm submachine guns
resulting in no damage change so it's
just moving things around as a result
terrible or how do people say that it's
terrible trauma
I've heard it both ways I'm sure I'm
wrong biblical passage because yeah and
huckleberry gained 10 percent damage in
both PvE and PvP sold 10 percent boost
there mmm good now exotic fun here's
where your K this is where you're like
alright I'm good I'm good it's Gavin
giving some love I might actually have
to dust one of these off and finish my
catalyst for sleep business what is this
I think I got it - OH
missed magazine size from 100 to 150 you
still have the ability to do you get
bullets back in that thing or is that
just like the Titan thing but that's
just the test
rather barricade that's the second
armored the auto roughly auto rifle oh
yeah I forgot you guys have that yes
increased PvE damage by fifteen percent
that's a chunk hi now I always wonder
when they're like auto rifles pde damage
increase like is is this on time yes
that's that's large which being sweet
business is going to be a problem right
we're talking back old school Street
business better than Calais phasing
plate faced man what do you know I used
to get a number be a thing yeah yes we
base is gonna be a problem continue
high-caliber rounds have been replaced
with armor-piercing rounds damage change
from fifteen twenty one base was
previously so it's up it's literally up
to on the base damage and rescission is
next so identical weapon no longer
requires you to be firing when you pick
up ammo to have it automatically reload
mmm sweet business is definitely gonna
be one you want to dust off sounds like
ya gotta grab that out yeah sure now
pulse rifles are my baby like pulse
rifles are fun and finally I'll finish
my catalyst or have a reason to PvE
damage increased by thirty percent just
straight up and this thing has the range
on it man this thing is a range baby I
love the we take guns psycho for two egg
guns that it's a sexy gun yeah
onam explosions I like to use that
specifically with my boy class to match
just void synergistic a void I gotta get
all man I love I love gravity question
though yo no faction rally how they got
a dropped on campus and some type of a
loophole man
I'd they keep wack keep waiting on that
stuff man I don't know I have no idea
great I still keep waiting on like know
what was the one I was joking about
thunderlord catalyst or yotan fabulous
I think they scared it was to billions
like we can't take this crap any
stronger
it's gonna be so we've actually a faster
reload speed ano 10 you could probably
do yeah stuff like that but I mean
something SunShot the one thing
everybody asks where they're like hey
this feels good explosions are awesome
magazine size was 8 it is up to 12 that
was seen impacts actually this is one I
know you always enjoy because that was
like graviton but like at that mid-range
in PVE pvp I didn't enjoy this but PvP
damage increased by 25% on vigilance
wings Osiris is being that has some of
the more unique ornaments that make it
look completely completely different
like Maz me looks like something that
fresh out of Zelda you ever seen that
one admit that's like yep so ornate and
weird then he's got the they got the
saint-14 one that's the one I use yeah a
14-1 and then the classic Osiris with
the Egyptian wing the game I'll be that
you're right that gun has three distinct
they're all over different yeah it looks
like three different weapons correct
crimson baby
this damage changed from thirteen point
seven to nineteen and then from 24 to 34
Basin precision so that's its large
mmm-hmm and finish that was causing this
weapon to deal higher flinch than
intended which well if you love it in
PvP it's gonna be a little less flinchy
but oh well merciless fix the missing
aim assist that for this weapon not sure
what that means but that sounds like it
was bad news yeah a sub spades momentum
or ease damage bonus is now affected by
range fella good good that one needed it
Oh ace of spades is it's brutal when you
face it just that aim down sights in the
radar and then let's battle
yeah but Lumina noble rounds should
apply their buff to allies more reliably
now and the colonies serve the colony
now functions this autoloading holster
does confused I've got it here hold
insectoid robot grenades quickly
repopulate the magazine from reserves
while the colony is unequipped
oh so it is supposed to be light
supposed to be autoloading holster but
apparently it was never did it Wow so we
got some perks changes as well
subsistence reduce the impact of this
perk on total reserves not sure gonna
sound clueless but I am on that one I'll
claim it ricochet rounds remove the
hidden range damage the ricochet rounds
remove the hidden bonus - damage
fall-off I saw Fallout tweet on this one
he's just like yeah he can't kill
coholic video oh my god he's just
sitting there like are you kidding I
jump man ricochet rounds I I could see
it they they don't like I mean but you
know like when is that one thing you
know say that perk so not a giggle move
that giant because that die was the girl
that was the girl no sorry fallout
fallout man swashbuckler perk now
activates when getting a kill with ball
lightning so if you are getting that
melee throw it out there and still take
the effect
grave-robber perk now activates when
game getting killed with ranged male
abilities similar one-two punch
basically they turned off being able to
kill rape rate Riven in less than three
seconds with this thing so fixing
one-two punch stacking with cross
counter and liars handshake being
absolutely broken so yeah gonna have to
be I'm honestly wondering with the
reload speed if you're gonna be able to
one phase Riven hmm or people relearn
how to do it right oh yay that's good
about me people have got one phase of
nothing for so long it wasn't a lot of
it also having to do with grenade
launchers grenade which is a powerful
but it's the continuous firing of that
grenade launcher yeah you're right
right so it's like I mean yeah that's
like to to to to to reload quick and you
still go you might be able to you might
have to get that like hammer strike or a
buff on there and you can I don't think
you can stack buffs either yeah you can
so like I'll be curious what they do for
these phases like raids may feel
different after this weapons alight
she's supposed to be more powerful than
well that's the same baby Nate well went
from 35 down to 25 for shadow key and
weapons is going up to 35 so weapons the
blob will be the same and you can stand
in the well but you won't have the
infinite reload the buff would equate to
be the same but the the like never
stopping firing will change GDPs yeah
mhm so that's most of the chance what do
you think man there's a lot of stuff for
weapons and that's probably not even all
of them like I said my article man I
mean though we can't complain for the
most part we got a ton of buffs we got
the majority of this is buff so this is
good stuff this is good stuff even get
PvE damage up which is cool I think they
balanced it by having the the miners
take a little bit more to kill you know
Sam in general so you got that cuz again
in a raising everything else up I think
I love the thought process with pulses
hand cannons and machine guns damage
drop fall off you know saying moving
them back of living in their proper
range exactly that's where this should
be
this will open it up for scouts all I
need is Scouts I need to see a swab when
a perk line that says PvP damage agrees
and then I'll be finished ranting in
rate or I'll watch for scouts but for
the most part it's gonna be fun man we
don't get the chance to dust off new
stuff I love like meta stuff is my thing
this is my champ I get excited for this
stuff for this kind of stuff for my ball
now am i okay and now with the exotics
boom sweep business is gonna be serious
graviton I get to touch again cannot
wait man Crimson's another one man
that's what about you what are you
excited to dust off graviton for sure I
I've rarely had a use for sweet business
so I'm actually kind of excited to be
like might be fun Sun shots always cool
vigilance honestly vigilance is one of
those I always describe it when I do my
videos as it's just a workhorse it's a
good gun but it just never felt quite
strong enough in PvE compared to some
other things but 25%
is yeah that's a chunk and just it was
always it's that it's not long range
like graviton and hit graviton is longer
for sure it hits um farther but mean
that I would say perfect middle pulse
range vigilance felt just like even in
PvP to was just like just that like it
always felt really solid the bullets
come out really fast they're reliable to
hit all five I always enjoyed the weapon
it just got out shined later on and I
think this actually is I think they're
doing a few tweaks here that actually
feel like they have a chance to make
some of these weapons that have kind of
trickled down a little bit maybe shine
just enough that you might actually be
like I could bring that with me it might
be one like I agree
that could be kind of cool so yeah I
mean for me it's like those top for
basically a vigilant sunshine graviton
sweet businesslike all of those the OG
exotics that have been neglected for a
year and we're finally getting the
reason to kind of go back in use so
that's those are exciting for me I'm
kind of kind of pumped about that Bluff
City one more thing for the reckoning
mmm
destiny to update two point five point
two point two which my god I hope they
fix that numbering scale at some point
recently brought some frequently
requested quality life changes to the
reckoning next week one more changes
coming and I don't know if you have ever
played a reckoning that much how much
have you spent in reckoning oh I was a
huge fan reckoning when I first came out
September 17th
all negative modifiers this is so you
this is so you used to roll your eyes no
it's not doing it look down below and
this is the I think this is the main
reason why is because people have
finally said reckoning blackout no just
not doing it and especially for the
blackout dark blade nights nice sucks
that fight is like one you could burn
through phase one and two do fine on the
bridge which is hard enough it's
probably as you know get down there and
just cuz they will eventually run it to
be close to you smash the ground you're
dead a lot you're good and it cannot res
cuz they're slowly walking around
waiting on you
so yeah that and I think that's just
gonna open up it as a more viable option
for people yet to go farm it is starting
on the 17th hell yeah
so yeah all it's just gonna be will
continue feature feature weekly sins
with a daily rotation of brawler
grenadiers and heavyweight so it's
literally just gonna like a strike
playlist yes so you're gonna get a singe
and a buff so you go in there with like
Ark and heavy weight bring your Thunder
Lord or delirium in there and as stuff
has less health in there man you just
gonna be mowing stuff down now so yeah
our goal is this change to improve the
replayability of reckoning so players
feel more inclined to hop in to
matchmaking and I think that's legit
thing matchmaking that is always just
awful usually especially now I mean you
have people like fallout had like spare
rations day I think it was yesterday
actually so there are certain days where
like the load outs will change up a
little bit
mm-hmm but it's always been one of those
things there's like going into
matchmaking on a tough day it's just
it's not worth it it has not been worth
it now it's like it's gonna be more
viable
it's a farmable activity you're going
for so many rolls in there I mean you
look on this picture there's one two
three four five yeah seven eat not like
nine ten weapons in there so you got
enough things that you gotta try and get
rolls on rolls on them in general if
you're gonna farm it it shouldn't be
like just awful especially as an old
thing so like I should be a nice
improvement so if you're going for spare
rations farming that is gonna get a lot
easier basically Zilla has a couple
weeks so you have the week of a
seventeenth which I don't know if it's
gonna be because there's one week having
spare Russians has a better chance
depending so depending on the week
either so week of the 17th or week of
the 24th one of those will be your best
option to go for your final spare
rations farm and just pick the right day
with heavy weight and just destroy
everything
there's none working against you anymore
so that's good agreed
a reminder to everyone if you play on if
you want to link your battlenet account
to Steam do it before October force that
first or you won't be able to please
even have one your buddy of mine who has
not played that much like please please
please if you blame bad on that you
haven't linked it to steam yet please do
it because battle
shuts off on the first and you're not
getting yourself back hey and I getting
that back no you don't do that link it
over get it linked like you don't even
have to buy it yet but get it linked get
on that yes well yeah big that is big
and then to wrap up Dylan actually kind
of talked about his story in the past
five years which is cool we caught him a
little bit at Guardian con and talked to
me a lot actually he was I mean they
were everywhere but he was all over the
place
mm-hmm but I mean he went through work
on the Destiny reddit and I mean through
different things in different places his
is just one of those stories that man if
you'd like crazy things have happened
and his is pretty cool oh yay story's
insane yeah his is pretty awesome but
that is mostly it for the twelve we got
a lot of sandbox changes coming
reckoning is getting another tweak
Menagerie buffs are going away by the
way which we know like the ones we're
getting are not staying around you do we
know when the cutoff is photo because
I'm trying to get my Imperial decree I'm
trying to look through cuz last week was
the 12 of Ault wahb's yes there's like a
line somewhere and I'm trying to find it
but basically the idea is I thought like
the buff where it goes from two and then
three and then four and then five that's
not gonna stay I don't know what I keep
the two or not even or if it's truly
just gonna go back to like default but
one way or the other like the buffs
we're seeing right now in menagerie are
going to basically be going away at the
end of the season oh I'm sorry I was
like oh we're kind of wrapping stuff up
you maybe might need another shot of
coffee yeah I forgot about the calendar
I'm sorry I'm trying to power yeah
really hold on all right shake out the
King shakily yes we got a road map sir
holy calendar of crazy okay so first
I've been talking a lot I'm gonna let
you start this one out I'm gonna let you
take it looks like he's that a calendar
man we got a lot you know they
definitely drop that and if you want me
to break it down
civically / launched a and then we'll do
your day by day
yeah man surprise birthday haha nice we
gotta roll back man so got some day so
this is what's going on so left side we
have launch day shadow keep launch
destiny to base game now free to play so
that's for our new light Guardians that
we jumping in there all you blueberries
come one come all we are welcoming you
do got these guys get a lot of stuff bro
moon destination opens seasonal artifact
they get they get the finishes they get
armor 2.0 they get two new strikes the
festering core and the Scarlet to keep
crucible updates they get reprise pvp
map widows court reprise pvp map
Twilight that those that those are no
g-class yes of course very gonna be new
PvP map fragment then they get crucible
labs elimination I was surprised they
got crucible labs and free seasonal rank
rewards which we saw as part of that
track cuz maybe enjoy and then comes the
final season of the undying October to
December we have some very specific date
job and October 5th which I believe is
that Saturday yeah the ray a blues a
garden knows salvation right you got it
garden oh salvation when it is
accompanied with something what is going
on it affects offensive begins on the
same day they're interlinked what fire
now that's actually cool like the Ravens
the vex coming in and the vex offensive
art tied together so this is actually
kind of an interesting well I can't talk
today I'm sorry yes mhm an interesting
thing because the raid is not tied to
the like shadow keep blunt blade is tied
to the season it's like it's different I
mean I guess that's how we got like
scourge of the past any other stuff but
it's like even the base rate is not tied
to shadow keep so technically the way
I'm reading this graph if you didn't buy
a shadow keep much you bought season of
the undying
you wouldn't technically be
play the rate questions she's right
that's interesting so yeah if you only
want to spend $10 and play the seasonal
stuff but not really sure about shadow
keep yet and what's gonna happen on the
moon I guess you can skip it but I
wouldn't but yeah the fact they launched
on the same day basically like we go to
the raid crazy stuff goes nuts then the
VEX of it I wonder if it's gonna be like
the raid for the Dreaming city is it
gonna kick like when we beat is it
whether we go into the raid or is it
when like hey when the raid is defeated
okay there's a cinematic the veteran is
now when you're not paid because you
guys saw something we got to advise
place down like is that is I got its
might be a seasonal cinematic like beat
the raid everybody gets something that
might that be cool
I'm down so vex offensive begins on the
fifth what's next three days later 8th
we got oh what what we got hearts are we
going hunting what what is going on here
Oh alleged nightmare what is this
so any stuff okay we know there's three
difficulties and there's one listed
below which terrifies me yeah we know
there was a depth that's the basic one
at 860 power level that was the one that
had basically no modifiers on it at all
it just had like the one air superiority
I think it was called which never yeah
or that was the new one that was the
depth that's your base level you'd only
if you get about a week and then the
next week hero and legend nightmare
hunts lunch
so that's your hero was 920 if I
remember correctly for your light level
so 920 light level and then that had one
more modifier I think where it was the
know that at for that out for that had
the overload that had the barrier that
had air superiority and it had the like
for example the boss modifier or the
boss crazy it was the something of side
run so that one was on there yay so that
was on the hero and then legend added on
top of that match game and extinguish
yes so they get crazy hard that's only
8th now we national what do you think
nightmare hunts are oh um so when we
look at two things we've got scarlet
keep which is gonna be going into the
fortress scene that for the first time
probably the story mission that is on
the moon the other strike is not on the
moon but it is called the festering core
now we have seen images of phogoth on
the moon and if there's a strike they
descent on the moon but the strike is in
shadow keep one and two don't equal
three so therefore I think phogoth is
one of these nightmare hunts so I think
it's phogoth I think the ending of these
nightmare hunts are gonna be like the
crota phantasm the omnigul fans hasn't
even gotten phantasms you're gonna be
kind of going through a strike ish but
as they described in the lore or at
least in the little Vidak they said yeah
these are you can't defeat these enemies
normally mmm then it's not like you can
win against these we might be able to
like push back a nightmare or something
morning I think the idea behind these at
least the war effect is like if you go
through a strike and I kill septics like
in d1 why do I keep killing the same
dude over and over right right so almost
in like lore or theory like the
nightmare hunt is like this isn't almost
even something real that you're fighting
you're almost pushing back something
like temporal or like not real life so
that's my hunch is that's what those are
gonna be as a way to it's probably gonna
feel kind of like a strike but they're
gonna be specific to some bosses they're
gonna have certain rotations maybe
that's my guess what about you
or is that yeah no I think I'm gonna say
I think more wise I'm kinda in the
thought process cuz obviously we'll get
into the next one which it is I'll just
transition right now which is uh the
15th where the master you nightmare
hunts begin and then that character
looks awfully familiar you know this so
the vibe I got is just like oh you know
tormentors we get a chance to face and
all
you know with the Omni goals and you
know whatever hopefully I actually
would've liked office I mean I don't
know what but uh I kind of miss call
fell he was going very quick had
actually a cool story
did the dude then he can again uh he he
got a little high in my tea but yeah I'm
alright fighting him again phogoth will
be interesting so that's the eighth we
got the Hunts we don't know what they
are but we're good pregnancy the Adept
version in the first week so it sounds
like and thanks the Slayer for pointing
out by the way the icon next to the raid
launch is shadow keep not the season yes
that is true but I still think they're
gonna tie together so I'm waiting for
that yeah I think it's literally post
raid I mean Luke during it all his
interviews and two events leading to
other events that set off stuff I think
the raid completes we pissed the vessel
backs off royally and they're coming the
entire it's going down no yeah now what
is on the fifteenth because this is
brand-new information
yeah the fifteenth we talk about the
master diamonds correct yeah we haven't
seen master before yeah that's a brand
new dude that is like what is what is
that that is the fourth difficulty
because it wasn't hard enough at like
nine fifty already like what the hell
man yeah I realize man we got dangle
esoterical solo this one on day one oh
yeah shout out shout out the skills iron
banner on the same day I'll go ahead and
save my thirteen hundred in iron banner
tokens I've gotten just dump it into the
new season mm-hmm twenty second we get
the exotic quest leviathans right the
interesting name for a potential heavy
moe I Nell do you think we're gonna be
related to the Leviathan since everybody
is it for like you ain't going back and
we getting this from Calais it one would
a shul
names die together but it is seasonal
but it's vex are we going back in to
fight in are we going apartment to be
and fighting the dumpster the garbage
disposal
callous wants something excuse me
ring my bell I need services Guardian oh
my god yeah so that's the seasonal quest
let's burn the season right then we got
festival of the lost returning all right
229 that's fine there's more important
right next to it that's it all he's good
so I will leave this one to you what's
happening on a 29 29th we've got the
dungeon Lodge this is all the glory that
is the dungeon I want to shake his hand
oh man awesome dude by the way Roku Roku
yeah but seriously the dungeon launch I
don't know by the image I mean like I
can't see enough it's in the shade it's
in shadow key ok looks like it for sure
the only thing we've seen is like they
mention a dungeon there these light
rotating cylinders with spikes on them
that are doing this up and down mm-hmm
sorry if you listen to this on audio cuz
you can't see what the hell I'm doing
but it's like three rotating cylinders
that kind of move up and down on a track
and they've like rotating spikes so it's
gonna be like kind of a not platforming
but almost like an old little puzzle or
timing that you got to get through so
definitely ways I'm sure to get really
into squished mmm yes well and then for
you we got a new mode oh yeah I'm a
little nervous though because even
though it's a new mode the name is
throwing me off so we got momentum
control well I just hope it ain't just a
control very as opposed to like a new
new new mode so that's my only thing but
I mean I'm gonna give it should I see
what what it's about you know there
I'm just control I just want to make
sure I just not you know control with
actually because they like just some
wheels like another control
we've seen good well mine so I'm just
hoping I mean that the even the icon
looks different yeah yeah yes to decide
so I have no idea if this is what this
is but one of the people in my chat
actually had a really good idea for a
PvP mode which is and it was a way to
use the infinite forest which is take
like take like all the platforms think
of just let I mean think of like
battlefield 5 take a platform if people
like take it over then you push to the
next platform and then if you can only
take that one over and push to the next
platform and it's like could you like
either like tug of war or could you do I
have no idea how it would work in there
but that infinite forest space where it
kind of builds the next platform you
have the driver I would think that would
be really cool like ok so if you die you
respawn on the next one that the team's
push into or it's like is it attacking
too thin I think like an attacking
defend or it's called rush or whatever
the hell that mode is called yeah yeah I
think that would actually really work in
infinite forest I think that actually
could be fun I don't know how if they
can do like 6 people in there but if you
take the enemies out can like the
systems handle it but I actually I have
no idea if this is it but it was like
momentum controls like are you picking
up momentum I was like it just made me
remember it because somebody said it my
chat recently it was like honestly that
would be a fun mode I have no idea how
it would work but I think that would
actually be a cool way like I think
that'd be a fun way to do a PvP match I
think that begin agree with you see like
battlefield rush bow capture points to
move to the next point rush bow yeah
yeah I think that would actually be
really really really cool so that was
when I saw but for me dude the dungeon
the 29th I am I am so there I can't wait
stream so we got that when I actually
like I said do we got two things yet
that dungeon you got that new PvP event
and then again on the 29th yep the
exotic quest at wait what is it that
divinity that look like a trace rifle we
raised the rifle crit spot making thing
I think right yes the 29th and that is
tied to shadow keep and then the first
raid challenge mmm now I don't know if
these are like the like are they
bringing back the challenge modes are
they doing that type of stuff I they're
bringing back difficulties but I don't
know if they're bringing back raid
difficulties I wish they would bring
back great difficulties because it made
things kind of fresh yes it was nice to
have the differences like you do get two
different gun models the harder one was
like I like how they did even what is
the what is the Seva raid random shame
yeah if you've ever done a podcast by
the way and you think people don't blink
the ones who never do you it's a boy
but yeah wrath of the Machine like with
the double drops I don't know of Indian
of all that stuff but you'd be I know
there are many people who would like
difficulties where it's like it's
designed for hard and they tone it down
for normal I don't know if the rain the
rain channel just never seemed to be
quite enough I guess I will say for most
people not me even that's for like those
and stuff out there it's just like it's
always like well how much can you really
do in this space if you just kind of
develop the one mode and you're like
well let's tweak something I'm when you
read leviathans one person has to stand
in the pool the whole time yeah it's
kind of annoying but it doesn't I mean
it's just you have to rotate differently
yeah I mean it's not crazy different so
I don't know we'll see about the rain
challenge I have pretty low expectations
for that one but then I just real quick
I think the fact that they even
mentioned in this stuff I think they
want to get back to d1 because that's
been missing with the Rays and stuff
like that so I can we get back to the
bottom what we got on that 19th May so
they state that this is supposed to be a
10-week season starts October 1st goes
ten weeks which will be mid-december mmm
right so that math right like December
15th if you're gonna do about right or
13th towards wealth whatever ten weeks
is gonna be we know it's a 10-week
season on the 19th which is almost a
month for
the end of the season so you'd have
probably a good three weeks I would
think from there you have the vex
offensive final assault when we came
back to the launch of all this news
about how the seasons are gonna work and
tying into this Lord air ative and
things are gonna get to a culmination
and tie into the next season this is
this so cool so let's go that looks like
the undying mind by the way mmm nice it
looks like the tree does it looked like
like literally it leaved up like nature
cover yeah undying mine because it has
the alone with that color shield mmm yep
yeah cuz the other hydras and stuff
throw is white he's got that orange
shield in the old strike if you remember
his was a different color final assault
so they are pissed yeah they've been
trying for like a month and half they're
like screw that noise we're going go to
town go I'm big it was huge Stefan huge
huge huge that's I mean that's where the
season will probably rap we'll have
three weeks of this offensive maybe
there's like a culmination as we go
through and then whatever happens with
all of this crazy seasonal stuff's going
on this is going to tie into season have
dawn now I'm wondering the first time we
log in and finally gets to see cuz
usually we look at the season and the
bottom right corner next season it'll
feel like season have done see that
little image will be interesting or if
they're just gonna like cut it out say
don't spoil it
cuz now you're gonna have like lore
going into the next season Oh big time I
can tell like boy Milan five
it'll be salivating man they got so much
to talk about but the key that this is
all I wanted late that narrative
cohesion that continuity that going
through from one thing to the next we do
something to reign boomers has effect
and it's literally everything like Luke
explained in one of his own directors
cuts how he would say you know there's a
thing that's gonna happen that's gonna
affect this you know we you know said
redacted gonna be fun this is what I
always always wanted I think it's gonna
be awesome
I'm hoping it's awesome so on this thing
obviously the VEX offensive is that like
is that top for you is that like the is
that like what's what's like top top two
things on this entire calendar what do
you got you don't mind minds easy number
one I think for me yet great offensive
is up they're very curious what that is
because it's that that narrative tie-in
rate is always gonna be you know race
yeah raids gonna be of course got
experience man I'm gonna be tuning in
what you don't work there's you know I'm
trying to keep my expectations low with
my midnight I mean Nightmare hunts just
to see you know just you know what that
is poor arm yeah I think for me the fact
that the reads or a challenges are
coming back you know offensively the VEX
offensive sounds cool and I know you
know for you what's going on so yeah I
mean dungeons my number one just because
those have always been awesome journeys
and experiences I can't wait to see what
they do with this one and for me I mean
I know the raids come and I know the VEX
offensive I honestly can't wait to see
I'm really curious what the hell a
master nightmare hunt it just because we
haven't heard of it yet we've seen the
other difficulties they scrolled through
them on the streams master hasn't shown
up any warrior I don't know if that's is
there gonna be one a week that's a
master and that's like bonkers crazy it
takes like is it gonna be above is there
anything that's gonna require above 960
power yeah is there anything with that
seasonal power when it comes in time
before two weeks in yeah well higher are
we gonna be I don't know he's own yeah
it's like I mean the VEX offensive ties
into the story we have a name on it now
but I'm intrigued about that but for me
is like I want to know what the master
is because I mean we're talking for
difficulties on an activity now have
much of any difficulties on activities
right now so I will be curious how those
are tied in and then of course the
dungeon that's that's my they seem to be
bringing Dave's team hell-bent on
bringing difficulty back challenges back
last question now as far as the UM
neither the the dungeon do you think
it's going to maintain its three-person
fireteam raid like experience do you
think they stay stick with the three
because that's in essence what a dungeon
well you dig they may open it up I think
it might still be three I think if a
dungeon if they still design it around
being so Lobel hmm I don't think you
could make it six because then if you
make it a six-person match main activity
you design it for that one person's eye
they're gonna be likely overwhelmed or
not be able to do all the mechanics
right and survive it I think if they
keep it at three one person can still do
what three can do because it's not gonna
be quite as bananas I think right
that's my guess I don't know there is a
cool addition not expecting freaking
amazing so I mean we do look we're
getting a lot of cots let's just call
what it do a lot of content this is
bordering like they will be to me I feel
like they're being I mean granted we
don't know what a lot of this stuff is
you know lengthwise and depth what but
you don't based just on paper this feels
bigger than a rise of iron expansion I
think people are like I think they're
almost I think it will be I was gonna
say I think people are not giving it
enough credit you know like new light
players get a buttload of stuff so much
stuff but I mean for a season we get
shadow keep we get the story that goes
with it we get the raid we get the
exotic quest we get the dungeon that
goes with it we get the nightmare hunts
that's for an expansion that is $35 and
comes with your season so yeah it's a
season on top of it which is the vex
offensive which is gonna be the final
assault and the exotic quest and like
those other things all of that is in
there plus armor 2.0 plus the weapon
mods get it corrected plus the sandbox
changes those are there but mm-hmm
for $35 it's not a lot of contact bro
that's a so much stuff in honestly if
you just paid $35 you would have this a
new light yeah you could go get for a
second later but you don't even need
forsaken stuff to do this yeah it's a
lot for that
that's huge I think and like I said the
free-to-play model is it's a lot it's a
large and then for the hardcore seems
like they're they are packing this thing
to the brim then on top of all the fun
the mental meta changes sandbox changes
like it's literally they're getting into
this almost revamping the game on its
head completely typing with the way I
play it's gonna be interesting man I
might this is a lot about I didn't
expect this much you know content the
way they think you and I'm happy that
the new light guys are gonna play a lot
they didn't be able to play a lot with
us yeah I think that's gonna be really
good I think I think it's gonna be one
of the better ways to jump into destiny
absolutely and if you like it you get
the t's on the moon you're hearing about
these thing you're like oh what's this
cool stuff and you're checking out
YouTube videos and you're seeing these
things there's a dungeon out there the
dungeons not gonna go away by the way so
that's part of shadow keep and then but
it's just like all that stuff's in there
it's like man what do I get now I do
what do I jump on I think they're doing
it right and I think this is looking
cool crossing our fingers on the vex
offensive tying in tying in well being
cool and then actually like maybe
building into I don't even know they
said the community event is going away
for a while so I don't even think it's
gonna be like that but hopefully if I
mean it's not the 19th and even if the
season ends on the 12th or 15th you got
about three weeks basically it sounds
like two we're somewhere in those three
weeks I'm hoping this builds like we
wanted something week two is crazy maybe
the end of week two is something then it
kind of trickles off into the next
season somehow it builds in that link
between the two seasons I cannot wait to
see agree exciting stuff yeah raid race
lunch
what's your over/under on dad Oh dad oh
yeah he's got to get number one now
oh man I found for him to put those like
really good content just bit he's been
trying too many times and even Luke
joked over the last time oh man that was
rough so yeah shout out I was like four
and I was like seeing new people get
first like whether it's an underdog or
somebody who's been at it but so close
definitely should be interesting so raid
launch is gonna be awesome
on that Saturday which is cool for
everybody have the weekend people don't
do what they can through Friday
sleep at breakfast get up kind of be
ready go and sow not like that might
need to be the new date that's but I
mean that gives most people the best
option I think that really is so will my
curiosity is the light level it launches
that in four days and how high we can
get in four days because we're going 752
I don't know
850 900 it's gonna be a leap so we will
see that's most of what we've got for
the day we're creeping up on hour and 45
so I wanted to ask as you've been
hearing a couple things about this other
game we won't touch on this long about
5-10 minutes but this other game that
came out that I'm probably gonna boot up
right when we turn off this podcast cuz
about any minds playing it but this
thing called Borderlands 3 so I played
for a couple hours but I want to know
with have you even touched it yet no I
just had to ask so I want to know what
you heard before I go with what I said
yeah I've been hearing things obviously
this is a highly anticipated title but
um you know I'm actually touching this
on LP as well but um yeah been hearing
this like a lot of reviewers weren't
getting access to the game so they were
all you're putting in their normal media
you know credential kind of thing and
you know they were just not getting and
for what I understand is the long story
short a very small amount were able to
get it and it was kind of mixed right
now again I can only speak for the
console perspective is comfortable I
know that have it already tried it
I'm hearing it does not run well on
console hmm it really struggles it's a
versus like exes or I'm even on the X
and the pros struggles to maintain you
know 60 strut like frame pacing issue
I'm hearing bad then performance class
for a couple people I trust um I did
hear some things that the human might be
a little awesome P I saw a couple
reviews I think PC gamer polygons didn't
I think PC gamer because they've even
seen that one it's been up for a couple
of days right it's I think some people
are really enjoying it
think it is from what I've heard is more
Borderlands you like Borderlands you
like humor right you're getting a lot
more of that but I know some people it's
just like it's too much it's there like
we'll see I'm literally like right hour
and half in so I'm like yeah so what's
your feeling on it I mean so far if some
people were where I was streaming
yesterday and I'm sorry if you guys are
watching the stream by the way again
it's been like right now it looks like
it's been fine but I've had definitely
some drops lately I don't get it if I'll
get a mess with that but people are
skinned it's like does it look less
cartoony and I will say it still is
cel-shaded but it is not Wind Waker
cel-shaded it is right pretty solidly
detailed like I picked sane that's what
I was gonna go with just cuz much Ben
type stuff but even like the hair the
shading and the details like it's it's
cel-shaded it's not like you know dusty
Guardian detailed but they did really
well with the models I mean for the art
style they're going for it's a detailed
like damn detailed cel-shaded like it
looks very good I mean I'm probably 1440
on PC looks pretty crispy so it wasn't
so good but it's yeah I minutes early
I'm like an hour and a half in feels
kind of cool I will definitely say
mm-hmm ammo mechanics are something I
got to get used to in that game and that
may be the game I've never played a
Borderlands but I was just going through
fight and there's a whole lot of these
just these little scrags or dogs or
something I was fighting and there's
quite a few of whom kept coming I didn't
have the greatest of weapons and I was
just I was like running out of ammo I'm
like where the hell do I get him I was
like running around my little shield
trying to punch this final dog and it
was like I nobody dropped me ammo what
the hell back to the vendor and pick
some stuff up but man I like I got to
figure out an ammo kiss situation but I
mean it's got a lot of dabblers gonna
have like little shields that you level
up your shield that has a stat to it in
itself weapons of course have crazy
amounts of stats there's skill trees
that you'll be unlocking so I mean it
seems like it's definitely gonna be a
fairly deep game how far you want to go
and the rolls of course are gonna be
crazy
and I think I'm headed towards the
mission that I played with you know in
Guardian cone so right the mission that
I played there as I think what I'm
heading to it's like mission your main
first thing that you'll fight so
one goofy little guy with a knife kind
of shot him and ran around and just
played keep-away mmm
I kind of Miss my I miss my destiny
mobility though my double jumps and yes
I'm able to I guess get away or just
yeah it's like I I feel like I'm just a
human running from other humans and I
know I'm not faster and I guess that's
how it's meant to be but it just feel
it's a different game so I don't know
I'm gonna try it for a couple weeks
shadow keeps definitely gonna take me
away from it but I got two weeks and not
much else on the plate right now
I do need to run crown of sorrow in the
next like three days nose out facts fact
I'm gonna hold off on a couple other
Ray's I really will run but I want the
armor 2.0 versions of gear especially
I've been stuff and stuff like that but
um yeah for you yeah you gotta get in
there you know what you call it that's
the only thing for my title so nice oh
yeah
so I'll be experiment on Borderlands if
my streams are not terrible you guys can
come check it out here but that's
probably I'll be doing for a couple of
weeks seeing how it goes you know
dabbling dusty stuff kind of getting
ready to a vault clean out at some point
clean up the mods we gonna get ready
cleaned out oh yeah vault clean out I
will be keeping a few things not much
like the god the god double roll like
machine gun scavenger and loader like
hold on to that for a little bit yeah
cuz like I don't know how long those
perks are gonna take but then I mean
most of that's going I mean I'm gonna go
if it's kind of split kind of half it's
going yeah what do you got left in Lex
couple weeks me okay say just a lot of
weapon clamp basically I'm just trying
to have the most productive weapons for
different situations and different
archetypes
so each whatever wherever the meta go
I'm gonna be right you know Zanna the
met is you know it's gonna be you know
Scouts we good got all the scouts I need
got my catalyst is done you never saying
that kind of thing so yeah that's really
what I'm doing it then just I'm farming
a couple of God rules I told you before
like I'm in in a menagerie a lot I got
I'm gonna get the heroic one done and
for the is an army on catalyst but I'm
also farming the UM the watch car I want
that Imperial decree with the trench
because I basically want
the escalation protocol shotgun in the
kinetic slot Alba fight they just won't
give me that damn trench barrel that's
what I'm going for right now I'm just
like anyways it was like those last
couple weeks if you're getting like five
drops at the same time or something
that's gonna be your time to farm so I
perform the fall manner
yeah I'm a foreman well you say five
Odle it adds per week until shadow keep
starts so it's like it's too possible
three three possible for four possible
five as you go through so like that last
week you're gonna be just like swimming
in guns yeah I'm getting called out
cleaning my vault see my brother jokes I
need to be about two drinks in on a
Saturday night doing a vault clean out
ASMR stream yes yeah that might have to
happen so goofy Saturday night if I'm
not doing watch no plans quiet quiet
night in mm-hmm couple drinks boot up
the stream have half stream voting on be
like keep it or go give the thumbs-up
that's right
start breaking them down I'll do that
I've all about this there we go it's got
to happen
mondo thank you for the the gift there
vagabond oh of course always but that's
most of what we got I think covered a
lot of it it's been still a decent week
of news because we had the interview we
had and then this thing only a couple
weeks left to go man
do you you say you can start counting
the sleeps yeah like oh we get about 17
days from it and then we end yeah I'm
had to come down that work sickness
works okay so I get a case of the WS is
the work sickness that work sickness
might be creepin out man flares up
Raunak Tovar man somebody to September
yeah strong it's the flu I feel like
crap ding what was that nothing
whoo huh what's happened
oh yeah that's all I got so you guys
know where to find me
Yvonne Tess everywhere I'll be streaming
plains of Borderlands dunes have all
cleaned out streams just follow me you
guys will know when stuffs coming it's
me
what do you got coming I know you got
some stuff coming up yeah in general
where that's no just in general with the
alpide everything that kind of stuff
which me yeah just I mean I think we're
at the point of like kind of wrapping up
if you got anything else you want to add
not yet for sure man you already know me
Lord Hockney iron Lord podcast when
y'all to YouTube this Sunday special
guests a man Lord of video production
it's not cold
Eastwood long overdue huge in the
community man this guy does tremendous
graphics thumbnails video dude you gotta
watch for this video I know he's more of
an Xbox content creator but I this guy
is like you never why go to the movies
and you hear that guy's like in a world
where his stuff is so good that like
marketing for Xbox it's like yeah we
want to use that you never saying or and
like even his um his thumbnail game man
it's it's like I've been guilty and
everyone in the community banks has been
guilty of googling and accidentally you
noodle utilizing something that he
created thinking it's an official
Microsoft thing that's how good he is so
yeah check us out Sunday new time cuz
we're in football season 11:00 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time please check us
out the Lord's will be in the big in the
building they have cold but that's a
surprise we're gonna talk about like
what's going on we're talking about a
little bit of death stranding talk about
later stream who knows what the hell's
go no nobody until they play that game
and then they're gonna play it and still
not know good GB dodo so oh yeah we
gotta talk about dad would talk a little
bit about plans would get that and then
oh yeah man to great topics on so so
please check us out also I could set
online little podcast on YouTube check
out king of the statues King is out here
killing it with these Marvel and DC
statues and also give me a synopsis from
what differs between the actual
character in the movies versus the comic
book
counterparts so it's really informative
he kills it with that stuff please
support that on the channel and of
course you already know every Friday I
am here at the campfire with my man II
support this we're doing good I'd love
to see the Karma's you guys really been
saying really nice stuff on Twitter we
really appreciate you guys supporting us
and getting this in this thing going and
of course last but not least your you
know me personally
Lords of gaming dotnet you know I try to
get as much articles up there as
possible please support the movement if
we see an article retweet it it helps us
we trying to get things moving and
shaking at these conventions and shows
and trying to get media so thank you so
much everyone for the support yeah I
think you said all that a colossal baby
said you got me smoked there man but
yeah it's same for me I mean you guys
know where to find me gonna be trying a
couple of things was trying to get a
little perspective so when I come back
into destiny you got I've got a little
bit fresher eyes jumping around and
stuff like that and guess who were gonna
go raid this morning apparently somebody
who's taken now we're gonna go say hey
to fallout we're gonna give him a little
shoutout
we gotta get follows yeah apparently
he's home on a Friday morning so thank
you guys for the great podcast go say
hello to fallout for all of us over here
at the last word podcast might switch
iron Lords all of you guys give Fallout
ghosts famous chat and say hello what
for number episode 73 it has been an
awesome one think you guys very very
much September 13th we're not that far
away so for this episode it has been the
last word password